the one thing about china you got to
respect man
they are so united at the top like
what when do you hear a poli obviously
it's communism and it's foreign
i totally get it yeah but xi jinping was
a quiet bureaucrat before he rose up and
became
stronger than mao yeah so you have to
you have to think about
in us like the the as much as you know
what the constitution was written i
wouldn't want to live anywhere else
it also reveals too many
of who's against who all you have to do
is watch the news for like a couple he's
like okay he hates him
she hates her they're on the same page
it looks like they're
on the same team okay good here's why
we're gonna negotiate boom boom boom
boom boom i
it's so easy to go up against us because
you know
hey well you know what uh trump said
about you the other day when we're
talking i just want to make sure that
you know that we have your back and
you don't think these types of things
are being played on a behind the like
have you ever had anybody that try to
manipulate and negotiate you and you're
kind of sitting there like wow you are
so
freaking good you would probably get a
lot of other people the way you just did
patrick let's just face it you're ten
times better than you know
uh bobby and i know bob is your boss and
i know this but
let's face it without you he's a nobody
and you know they're like
wow you are so deceptive buddy wow
just sitting there listening to the
language you know
adam you know if i was your girlfriend
you don't like a girl says that
you're not getting lice you're like oh
you would oh really you would treat me
better okay that's great you know you're
done
you're done we're going so we're just
giving our dirty laundry to the world
and saying hey
use this against us come on down and
it's making it so easy
so but that's not new right we've been
doing that for
you hundred something years not not 200
something years not 200 something years
because
200 something years ago media wasn't the
way it is
so when they came out with what they
came about back in the days you didn't
say something
two seconds later china already knows
what you said you said something
it may take two months until they find
out what you just said
okay so the speed of being able to
retaliate wasn't that quick when they
wrote the constitution today
i say something right now china could
have somebody watching us to make sure
we don't say anything bad about china
they have one job
monitor these podcasts to see what
they're saying specifically these guys
because she said stuff about china he
said stuff about china he said stuff
about china
we don't know this stuff on what they're
doing so easy for them to
do it today versus what it was 200 years
ago anyways
and they do it with no fear remember the
international court system came out when
barack obama was in office and said
china is violating international law
with
building out the south china sea and and
they're still doing it
and they're still doing it because the
united states looked the other way so
and now we have his protege bottom line
80 years old
we've been talking about china doing all
you know stealing intellectual property
breaking international law for a
generation for generation
wtf like when are we like is there going
to be a hot war
are we is there a cold war is a trade
war like what in the
end is actually going to happen are we
just going to talk about it and talk
about it and talk about it
like the the bitcoiners will tell you
that bitcoin is going to take over
but that means that the past 400 years
of history is gone
history because in the past 400 years if
you're going to lose
the reserve currency status which means
you rule the world there's been a hot
war involved
and that's just history there has been a
hot war
and who is building up their military
for the first time since world war ii
germany and who is now more reliant on
china for their economic growth
than they used to be from the united
states germany
so china is an interesting thing because
if you look where they're investing
money
in 2016 they put more money into the
united states than they did in europe
and then trump won and they quit putting
money into the united states and they
started putting money into europe
and if you think about world history and
building alliances and world
wars and hot wars you cannot have a hot
war
unless you have an alliance and that's
what china's building
very proactively who's on china's team
what kind i mean we know that they're
pumping money into
iran as an example and they're pumping
money into certain countries into africa
for sure but who's like i'm with china
no doubt what's up
look at look at south america and all of
the copper
soybean look at the exports look look at
who has
pumped up that entire subcontinent's
economy
in the last generation so these are they
have built out the infrastructure and
energy in africa
but i'm talking the big countries the
big countries of the world did i mention
germany
okay so germany's on team china not team
united states is what you're saying
they're not on team eu
it remains to be seen we all know what
happens when freaking germany gets a
freaking
uh army on its side but but but again
germany is building up its military well
you're saying
well you're saying alex you're saying
allies united states knows that we have
canada up here we've got uh you know
obviously every pretty much every
country in the eu we've got australia
we've got certain countries
all over the world that have our back no
matter what i mean we've got differences
what have you
what can you say about china who like is
russia have china's back
iran of course okay those two are there
saudi arabia saudi arabia it's on whose
side
china china we're on our way
to being independent energy-wise
so we don't rely on the opec nations as
we once did it
where is this going to culminate i guess
is my point is that we talk about it we
talk about it china's doing this china's
doing that they're going to take us over
20 we started talking about 1.9 trillion
dollars that's not gonna
that's not going towards job creation
we're still on the first topic by the
way we're back to bitcoin 1.9 trillion
dollars
um okay i mean you know
china is enemy number one so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye